私の日本家屋の 12 の隠れた特徴
フルハウス ツアー ビデオ ここにポイント
1 の屋根瓦 家の主な特徴の 1 つは
、家
が取り囲む
この
中庭です。
これらの特別な点は、これらが
実際に私の妻の祖父によって作られたということです。
彼はこれらを生計を立てるために私の妻と私
がこの
ような方法で屋根瓦を使用してリサイクルし、
この禅の美学を建築で作成するの
を見てきました。
彼女の家族の
DNAを家の2番目の
隠された全身鏡に注入していることも知っているので、今
私たちは家のギャングコンにいます家の
入り口ですが、これは
実際にはゲストのゲンゴンです私たちは知りません
ここに靴を置いて、ゲスト
が家に来たときにスムーズ
に家に入ることができ、靴やその他のものの上を歩く必要がないように
、これらすべて
をこのrに保管します おっと、これは一家団欒
で、家に来るときはこのスペースを使いますが、
このスペースの特別なところ
は、ドアの内側に隠されたこのドアの反対側に、この
全身鏡があることです。
あなたが去ると、
これにより、家のポイント3の他の場所にたくさんのスペースを占める
これらの立ち姿の鏡の1つが不要になり
ます。その
ため、ルンバがあります。その理由
は、ゲストを除くためです
この家の床面積はすべて
家の 1 階にあります。
これは、ルンバが本当に光る家のタイプです。
私たちは
早くから欲しいと思っていましたが
、購入した人々から多くの恐ろしい話を聞いてい
ました。 これらの 500 ～ 600 ドルの
ロボット掃除機
ですが、使用していないときはこれらの
充電ステーションがあり、部屋自体
が実際には驚くほど大きく、
最終的にそれらを使用することはありませんでした。 リビングルームの
このぎこちないセクションのような隅全体を取り上げて、
それを
またぐ必要があり、それにぶつかると、
実際よりも面倒になりますが、
私たちは早い段階でそれが欲しいと思っていたので、 私たちの
建築家は、ここにこの小さな収納クローゼットがあることを提案しました。
彼は、そのクローゼットの底だけを切り取って
そこに充電ステーション用のコンセントを入れる
ことができると言いました。
ルンバの利点と
、すべてが完了すると、自然に
家に帰るポイント4番目の隠し
ケーブル引き出しだから、この建築家について私がとても気に入っていることの1つは、
彼がYouTuberとして物を隠す方法です。私には
たくさんのあなたがい
ます USBケーブルを知っている hdmiケーブル オーディオ
ケーブルを知って
いる 建築家から手がかりを得る 手がかりを得る
机の下にこの引き出しを設置したので、あなたが
知っているカメラの装身具やそのようなものをすべて保管して
います 年に 1 度か 2 度、
本当に捨てることはできません。それらはすべて
下にあり、
使用していないときは見えず、気にも留めていないので、ポイント 5 は現在私が使用して
いるオフィスの照明
です。 オフィスと
元のツアー ビデオでは、
これらの
サイド ライトと天井に沿ったこれらのライト レールのおかげ
で、前のオフィスにあった巨大なライトと三脚をどの
ように取り除くことができた
かについて少し話しました。 この
ビデオでは
、これらすべてのライトの温度と明るさを実際に調整する方法については話し
ませんでし
た。ここにこの小さなスイッチャーがあり、これらの
ボタンを押し
て、これらのライトを暗くし
たり
、温度を変更したりできます これらで、そして
しばしば夜に
私がすることは、これらのサイドライトを除いてすべてを
オフにすること
です。ここに私のYouTube仲間の1人がいれば、この柔軟性を利用して撮影することができます。
の別の
部分の別のビデオ e オフィスは問題ありませ
ん。ポイント 6 はケーブル管理です。
これは非常に満足している結果です。ケーブルに関して
は、かなり厳しいセットアップ
が必要ですが、ほとんどのケーブルは見えないはずです。
その主な
理由は、
ほとんどのコンセントがその高さにあり
ますが、これが日本のコンセントの標準的な高さで
あり、地面から約10
センチメートル離れているためです。
この机の下にある2つのコンセントの高さはそれ
とは異なります 家の他のすべての
コンセントは、身を
かがめるか、机が非常に高い場合を除き、実際には見えない
ので、ここでしゃがむとイーサネットコードが見えるかもしれません。
実際に何が起こっているかを見ることができます 作業中は上から
見て
もケーブルがほとんど見えないので
、これがどうなったかとても満足しています。ポイント 7
は隠しストレージなので
、この部屋のどこかに隠しストレージがあります。そう
です。
それはタットの下にあります
畳を移動したり交換したりするときは、畳
の上部に大きな傷を
付けるのではなく、このような鋭い針のようなものを使用して側面を刺します。
そして
、私のオフィスのここに持ち上げることができ
ますここ
に収納スペース
がありますまた、考えたくないが捨てられないさまざまなものを保管するのに最適な場所な
ので、
私たちは現在キッチンにいます これ
は私の後ろにあるパントリーで、パントリー
を塞ぎたいときはここにドアがあります。
私の妻は
ここに小さな机を置いています。もし彼女が
個人的な時間を欲しがっていて、あなたに知りたいの
なら、私からの避難所を見つけてください。
これは実際
にはドア枠の反対側に
あるのですか?飛び出すこの黒板があります。
これの全体的な目的
は、妻が何か
を調理しているときに何かをすばやく書き留め
たり、彼女が書いたものを参照したりする方法を提供する
ことです. ダウン以前にも
彼女の手がベトベトしているとき、手全体にグリースが付いている場合、または手全体に小麦粉が付いている場合、またはそのような場合は
、高価な1000ドルのiPhoneを取り出したくないことを知ってい
ます
が、それがチョークである
場合は、あなたは 私たちがここに置いている小さなチョークがある
ことを知っていて、彼女は
物事をすばやく書き留め
てから、キッチン
と調理の最中にここを行き来する
ことができます。
オリジナルのツアービデオで家のデザイン言語を
話しまし
た壁から出てくるこれらの将棋の和紙のドア
は部屋の雰囲気を変える素晴らしい方法ですが、非常に強烈な日本語を遮断できる
ので非常に実用的でも
あります
夏の太陽 夏の間、日本はとても暑くなるので
、私は頭を剃りました 私は禿げて
います それは別の理由ですが、暑いので
、この窓用の紙のドア
と、その上にあるはるかに大きな
窓があります たぶんあなたはその瞬間のショットを撮ることができるかもしれません
が、ポイント9は実際には
これです。これらの窓用の電動ロールスクリーンは、
同じ基本的なアイデアの上にあります。
夏は
一緒に行ったかもしれ
ませんが、家のこの種のエリアを常に走っ
ている2人の娘と2人の小さな娘が
いることを少し心配
して
いました。 彼らは
その中に張り巡らされ
たり、腕がそれに引っかかっ
たりして、天井から全体を引っ張ってしまうかもしれない
ので、私たちは電気を使い
ました。
いいえ、天井から床までずっと続く
これらの 2 つの大きなひもはありません。
現在、
家族のクローゼット エリア
にあります。
元のツアー ビデオで話さなかったものの 1 つがこれです。
これは
完全に別のスペースに上がるライナーです。これは
実際には収納スペースです。収納スペースなので、がらくたでいっぱいな
ので、皆さんにはお見せし
ませんが、少し
の映像があります 東京レンズの友達のノルムが
登ってあそこの空間に反応する
のでここにドロップします
[音楽]
ああ、ここは実際にとても広々としています
緊急用備品ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
限り 私たちは現在
、温泉につながるランドリーエリアにいます。
入浴スラッシュ温泉エリアと
ポイント11
はこれです。これは
、洗濯機スラッシュ乾燥機を使用して洗濯できますが乾燥しない衣類用の物干しラックです。
調節可能です。
私は非常に背が高いので、私たちにとって本当に素晴らしいです。つまり
、この高さでは私がそれに遭遇することを知っ
ていますが、
これよりも高く設定する
と、妻が使用するのは非常に困難になり
ますが、それを超えると
あなたは濡れたclの束を知っています
ここにぶら下がっている他のものは、
このエリアを使用するのが非常に難しいので
、服を掛けてから
、服全体
をこれに掛けて、持ち上げて
、朝顔を洗ったり
、歯を磨いたり、必要なものを何でもしたりできます
ここで次の洗濯物を干すに
は、これが衣類を掛ける最大の高さのようなものですが、
もう一度ボタンを押したままにすると
、天井まで届くので、
これがゲストルームです。
仲間が来て、
一晩滞在します。これらの
シーリング ライトの 1 つが、より伝統的な
日本のシーリング ライトです。
リモコンを使用してオンとオフを切り替えることができますが、
このビデオ ポイントのグランド フィナーレのようなものです。 番号
これだと思い
ます。このライトアップは、実際
にはアラジンのポップと呼ばれるこの製品です。シーリング
ライトですが、ワイヤレス プロジェクターでもあり
ます。 ゲストはいますが、ゲストが
いないときは、デッド スペースのようなものです。
実際には
、古い家からこの
プロジェクターを持っています。
消して、私たちに
は子供たちがいて、彼らが常にテレビを見ていなければいいのですが
、建築家
は、このドアを閉めたらゲストルーム
もシアタールームに変えましょうと
言い
ました。 また
、
そのライトをオフにする
と、この大きな大きな画像が壁に表示され
ますが、標準的な
日本の天井照明コンセントに
接続するだけで、すべてワイヤレスであるため、
階下に Wi-Fi ルーターがあり、現在
私たちに光を当てています。 クリス・ブロードのことを知ってるよ
、ここに座ってこのお手玉の椅子を使ってリラックスし
て、家族との素敵な時間を過ごすことができるよ
ディズニー映画やハリー・ポッター映画など
、ゲストがここにいるときにやりたいことは何でも
見よう
部屋の半分をふさいでいる
たくさんのケーブルは大丈夫ですが、それ
はビデオです。
知らない人のために楽しんでいただければ幸いです。patreon
で高低アクセントで日本語の発音を教えて
います。下の説明にリンクを残しておき
ます。
さようなら
[音楽]